hello everyone welcome to the genetics
and genomics Wachtel event
my name is Yin Phan Jiang I'm a senior
scientist West Midnapore Sigma based in
Missouri set louis missouri together
with my colleague Michelle ting a
scientist in our group where we'll be
talking to you about being perceived as
newest strategies a crisper case 92 box
was utilizing visualization and
increased chromatin accessibility please
feel free to submit questions during our
presentation and we'll be following up
with you as who emails afterwards during
the first part of our talk I will first
to give you an overview of our company's
CRISPR portfolio then I'll introduce to
you our newest case 9gp fusion product
which can be used for visualization of
the CRISPR system sigma-aldrich is a
pioneer as commercial provider in
targeting the genome editing tools with
over 14 years experience starting from
the first generation genome editing
tools such as tacit Ron and zinc finger
nucleus sigma-aldrich has become a
prominent leader in the field of CRISPR
cast line system development we have we
have our first Christmas night product
launched in 2013 and since then we have
continued to over to our customers a
great variety of CRISPR products
including some of the award-winning
technologies such as the CRISPR
epigenetic activator in 2015 the
reknowned Sanger CRISPR libraries in
2016 the CRISPR cell libraries in 2017
and most recently the proxy Chris for
instance
aging the sycamore tree CRISPR portfolio
consists of a variety of deliver format
lentivirus carrying the Xmas systems can
be transfected into almost all cell
types especially those hard to transfix
allies lentivirus is also the courier
for our reknowned Sanger Christopher
libraries we also offer a great
selection of plasmid carrying the CRISPR
systems available for purchase at those
deep redesign the form and the customer
designed form the plasmid en can then be
transfected into the desired is ionized
the Xmas system encoded into the T RNAs
are also available for embryonic back
injection purified CRISPR contain
proteins together with guide RA can form
protein are in complex which we call arm
P so the arm P deliver format has been
more popular and preferred in recent
years and the iron P can be either back
we injected or transfected into the
desired satellite and this is going to
be the major focus for my talk today on
top of the individual whatever format
sigma-aldrich also is the provider for
the whole genome CRISPR libraries either
in the rate form of the pod form
including our award-winning technology
such as the Sanger genome whole genome
misra library or the Christmas and
library sv Krishna is the first
discovered CRISPR system and has been
widely used in the genome editing field
also the RNA protein RP complex is the
preferred method for delivery in the
recent years over a sigma-aldrich spgs 9
is purified from e.coli and has nucleus
localization sequence fused to C
terminus to in for efficient new
delivery into the cells the purified s
because nine together with guide IRA can
form the RNP complex to be transfected
into the cell lines the guide IRA can
either be in vitro synthesized into a
single strand or it can be ordered
through our medieval Sigma Sakai
assistant so the Sicari can either be
one single strand Sakura or it can have
two parts the universal trees are a
together with the crispr RNA that's a
complimentary to the pocket and cigar a
can be easily used to form army complex
with the pure violence because nine and
ready for transaction using the armpit
level format has the advantage of
possibly eliminate the unwanted random
integration on the genome therefore
reduce off target effects over Saiga a
system is convenient efficient and
hassle-free on the customer site there
is no cloning or image line synthesis is
needed and also we provide a pretty
short lead time about three to five days
you will be getting RA and also the RA
can be chemically modified and scaled up
Sigma objects has a comprehensive cast
nitrogen portfolio the canonical
wild-type SP cani can be used for
standard genome editing and cloning
applications we also have two versions
of import as weak as nine the econ Stein
and perdicas
both of which have higher fidelity that
can be used to reduce off target effects
we also have a special FM cast nine that
we cloned and purified for a bacterium
called Francis Silla novice EDA and the
ethicist 9 can work as a programmable
restraint enzyme for cloning large
genome fragments into the vectors we
also have the catalytically active
decays nine
fused with black tag and bounty tag that
can be used for pocketed the genome
binding isolation and enrichment the DK
9 is also the essential component for
our proxy CRISPR technology which is a
normal technology developed by MIDI for
Sigma for increasing the editing
efficiency for some non canonical CRISPR
systems lastly we're going to talk to
you about our new cast 9 protein product
which is the cast 9 JP fusion protein
that can be used to visualize the CRISPR
system in cell before we designed our
case 90 of the fusion proteins we first
took a look at the available similar
fusion protein products available in
market from other suppliers and it
turned out that all of those fusion
proteins fail to give good editing
activity inside the cells so s because 9
is rather large protein at 163 kilo
doctor fusing 27k a GFP may most
possible delay compromise the folding of
both s9 + JMP therefore you have
decreased nucleus activity and decreased
for answers and we suspect that this is
probably the reason why the similar
fusion products forum as a supplier
failed to have good activity to solve
this problem we decided to design a
specific linker sequence between the GFP
in Kenai the idea is to put 2 protein
part at optimal geometrical distance so
that each of them can fold properly and
giving good activities we had to
actually experiment several different
linker sequences and with their relative
positions to the Castile working we also
engineered 3 optimized nuclear
localization sequence
for enhancing the nuclear deliver inside
cells finally we also carefully designed
the expression and purification system
so that we can make sure that we have
high yield in a high purity in the
protein production in this slide you can
see some beautiful green colors here the
strong green flat for essence was
visible throughout expression and
purification and procedure and in fact
the green style palette became a good
indicator for us as to whether the
expression level was good why not
the middle picture shows you the binding
of kiss 90 fusion proteins to the nickel
nta reason so the nickel column the
natural color is light blue upon binding
the kiss ing diffusion for teens the
recent becomes strong green color and
when the fusion protein is ruled out
the reason turns back to the light blue
on the right
this figure shows you four individually
purified fusion proteins that we have
each wears a different linker
configuration you can see all of them at
5 milligram per ml the differences in
the fluorescence intensity indicate that
indeed the ingre sequence has effect on
the protein folding and we decided to
choose the one with the strongest
flashes for our production we also want
to make sure that our fusion proteins
have good editing activity in status
house since ESI cut a different
chromosome target at different
efficiencies and the efficiency can also
be different in different cell lines
we tested 10 target sites in multiple
cell lines and examined those the on
target and off target activities because
we want to make sure that fuels energy
ptoo Walter can I didn't alter the
off-target property of the exam so that
there's no more of target effect
generated we si our editing results by
boast t7 even gol sa which is a cement
quality Si and also with next-generation
sequencing which is a more fond of the
way to a sea of adding efficiency this
slide shows you just this is just a
subset of T at any efficiency data that
we have this specific experiment was
done in you to ourselves by armpit chest
faction and what you can see here at the
left to set up data's are the two s 9jp
fusion proteins found two other
providers they both have really low
activity across all four targets the
middle two sets are comparing our test
night GMP fusion to the knife used last
night while Turkish night counterparts
and you can see the Cassadine chappie
fusion proteins has the same level of
activity comparing to the wild-type all
four targets the right two data sets are
comparing the ekeus 9g at the fusion to
is iike Stein now fused counterpart
so the reason we also wanted to make a
ye can Sanjay diffusion is that for some
customers and some us specific
applications they prefer to use the high
fidelity ecad line to reduce of targeted
effect I want to point out here that the
on target activity of ek9 is in general
lower than the wild-type especially in
the armpit format and you can see from
our data that over ekeus 9gp fusion is
not only having a similar activity to
its non fused
ich as my counterpart it also has higher
activity than the two
while typecast 9jt fusions from our
competitors so this set of data here
clearly demonstrate that over s9g fusion
proteins have superior activity
outperforming the other similar fusion
products available on the market one
application for the caste 98 diffusion
is to visualize the forest ins inside
the cells in this set of microscope
pictures with what we can see is that
right after the transaction the for
essence is visible inside the cells but
the signal is mostly in the peripheral
side of the cells then one time passes
the fluorescence becomes more centered
in the south to summarize sigma-aldrich
is brent leader in genome editing
technology providing a comprehensive
portfolio of CRISPR case 9 products over
Newcastle GP fusion proteins of a
superior editing activity to forming
similar products from other providers
the case 90 diffusion proteins are quite
tools for visualizing the crystal system
inside the cells and now I'm going to
turn it over to my colleague Michelle
who is going to tell you over a novel
Christopher's technologies developed in
medical Sigma Hey hi everyone my name is
Michelle King and I'm a research
scientist at Millie for Sigma and today
I'm going to talk to you about some
novel CRISPR technologies developed by
scientists at Middlemore Sigma and as
you know has just talked about the
CRISPR system has become the rock star
of the science community in the past few
years and it has a wide range of
applications from food industry to
agriculture or jus from a suit eco and
medical field and although this
technology is very advanced but there
are still some hurdles that preventing
this from unleashing its fullest
potential for us to use and this hurdles
include some off-target cleavage or some
low entity editing activity in those
difficult to cut genomic regions or in
those hardship transfect cell lines so
currently there are several ways for us
to improve the CRISPR editing tech team
''tis and this includes the introduction
of the nuclear localization signal or
using a chemically modified single part
guide RNA to enhance its stability or we
can add adjust the RNA and protein ratio
in RMP transduction to maximize the
editing efficiency and today in my talk
I'm going to explore this field from a
different perspective and especially on
how we how can we improve the editing
efficiency on on those difficult to cut
genomic sites and the to technology I'm
going to cover in today is the proxy
CRISPR and the CRISPR chrome and the
both of them have been published in the
peer-reviewed journal on the nature
communications and the CRISPR Journal so
before we begin let's talk about some
basic science so we all know that each
human cell has 23 pairs of chromosomes
for a total of 46 and some cancer cells
has 3 sets or even more chromosomes and
actually if we line up all the DNA
molecules within the single cell and the
total length can be over 6 feet and it's
so it's very fascinating to imagine how
can a single cell packed such enormous
genetic genetic information in a tiny
nucleus which is often 5 micrometers
wide and actually the secret to this
super packing system is the chromatin
structure so if you look at this
illustration the DNA first erupts around
the histone protein to form the beast on
a string and then it forms a helix fiber
and then the super coil and eventually
it forms the chromosome structure
if the DNA is not being actually
transcribed it remained tightly packed
in this system so so for need for the
cell itself this super packing system
creates a lot of advantage for them and
saves a lot of space but for us
scientists who wants to manipulate the
DNA a great problem for us because if
Christopher doesn't even have access to
the DNA of course it cannot do a job and
in this slide I want you to do I want to
give you some perspective on how the
genomic sequence or structure can affect
the cast knife cutting capabilities and
in this experiments with designed dozens
of guys on two genes the CA r and the PR
genes and then we compared a cutting
capability of post FN + SP caste 9 so
Yvonne has just touched upon every caste
night a little bit and I won't want you
to know that so previously people only
observed the cutting ability of earthen
cast night in test tubes and it remain
remain um what we are active on most of
the target sites and that's kind of
consistent with our observation here so
among most of the guides that we tested
the cutting property of FN is very
distinctive from SP and it remained kind
of inactive on most of the sites but on
some sites it showed some activity and
another striking observation I want to
make out of this figure is that if you
look at some of the guides that within
only 50 per base pair range on the
activity varied a lot and it can vary
from almost no honey to 40% cutting and
these observation really led us to think
how can we better overcome on the
inhibition from the genomic structure of
the DNA onto better facilitates to test
night cleavage and in this proxy CRISPR
technology we leveraged the help from
the
you detest nine proteins and the D has
nine by its eyes name is dead cast nine
so this the T has nine still has the
ability to bind an unwind DNA but it
does not have the cutting function so if
we leverage the help of the 2d cast 9 to
open up the DNA on the two ends of the
interest of the sequence that we want to
edit it will make way for the major cast
night to come in and do the real job and
so in this experiment we also chose the
F and catheline and as you can see in
the figure that's on the second column
if by the FN chance 9 itself it doesn't
cut at all and when we have either of
the D cast night it doesn't cut either
but when we began to combine the decaf
light onto the ethicist night we began
to see some cutting activities and when
we have two of the D cast night presence
the Cadi activity has been significantly
improved and another thing is to achieve
the best results for the proxy CRISPR
technology usually we recommend
designing or a guide sequence for the in
cast night about 20 to 30 base pair from
the pam sequence and in a crisper chrome
technology we want to explore whether we
can leverage the function of the
chromatin modulating peptides to enhance
the cast night cutting activities and
the idea is that by having the chromatin
modulating peptides we hope they can
interact with DNA and also make it more
accessible to as to the calf night
proteins and we fused to several
promoter modulating peptides to both the
n terminus and C terminus of the s of
the proteins and by testing 3:33
constructs we eventually narrow down the
candidate to three constructs which are
shown on the slides here and for all
these three constructs they all have the
hl1
motif on the n terminus which is the
human
high mobility group protein and on the
c-terminus we have three different
module module eaters and it's HD one
that's the human high mobility group box
a domain and h1g the human histone h1
central globular domain and the CH D one
it's the East chromatin remodelling
complex DNA binding domain and the for
the rest of my talk I will be referring
them to the CMP so here we select for if
difficult to cut genomic sites and
compared the fusion or the CMP fusion
constructs to the wild-type and in dose
or insertion deletion percentage was
detected by the mismatched assay and as
you can see in a figure that for the
fourth on low activity target the world
type cuts on the activity comes from 2.2
percent to 4 percent so it's pretty low
but with the presence of the cmp fusion
we see that the cutting activity
dramatically improved with 3 to 6 fold
and then next we used the deep
sequencing to have a deeper look at the
mutation profile generated by the
different constructs and we can see in
the figure that's the mutation profile
the peak sequence are the pink position
along the edited region pretty much
aligned with the wild-type protein so
this indicates that there is no
influence or the cmp fusion doesn't
cause any change on to the wild-type in
the in hej repair pathway and then in
this experiment we expand on the jihad'
guide onto 12 sites and we selected six
targets from the emx one site and also 6
targets from the PIO our genes and we
also narrow down the accounts for the
cmp fusion construct onto just one and
the reason is because that
for the third construct the h and 1 CH
d1 is the largest among all and even
some has briefly touch about the size
issue of SP cast 9 because SP cast 9
itself is already a very huge protein
and when we add more motive to it the
size might become an issue in some
downstream applications so the smaller
the better so we eventually decided you
know to choose between each 2 h + 1 or h
p1 or or the other H of 1 H 1 G and
among these two constructs that h1 1 h
p1 construct perform slightly better
than the other one so we chose that to
proceed with this testing and as we can
see here on the target activity was
selected was expanded from low activity
and here it's some of some of the
targets have low and some have high to
our moderates cutting activity and we
can also see that for the low activity
target the wild type the process of the
cmp fusion dramatically increased the
cutting percentage and if you look at
the pors py6
targets the world type cuts at 7% and
the cmp fusion protein has at 38.8% so
it's fivefold increase well if the
target itself has a high activity to
begin with such as the AMX 1 SP y 10
site the world had cuts at 41% editing
well the and then the increase in the
editing efficiency by the fusion complex
is not very significant and this might
be because when the guide itself is
already active then it the system might
be saturated and then it's just leave
little room for the cmp fusion to do its
job and in this slide we set out to
compare on the
HDR and nhej a repair pathways and we
were just wants to explore whether this
cmp fusion strategy can be used to
facilitate the HDR based precision
genome editing and post HDR and energy
ej events were evaluated through deep
sequencing here and we introduced a
single stranded DNA donor with with its
history digestion site for the
downstream analysis and so you can see
here so the percentage of HDR and NH
agent event have dramatically increased
with the presence of the fusion proteins
and that's also because the overall
improvement on the editing efficiency
with the fusions job strategy and if we
compare the HDR versus nhej a ratio so
for the world had cast 9 + h + 1 HP one
protein the two protein the HDR and
energy generation remains around one and
for the hm1h one gene construct on the
HDR versus image each a ratio is around
1.5 so it means that these constructs
actually preferred HDR with versus n h
ej and then in terms of the h + 1 c HD
one construct the HDR ratio versus h and
h ej actually dropped to point 6 so it
means these constructs actually prefers
nhej a repair pathway so all these
results implied that on these fusions
the NP fusion strategy can potentially
be used to improve the HDR based the
precision genome editing and after our
initial success with SP cast night we
next want to explore whether the
strategy can be applied to other novo
cast night system and the reason why we
want to use some normal cast nicest
comes it's because they usually have a
different Pam sequence and although the
SP cast now usually is the most popular
protein on the market on its Pam
sequence and Gigi sometimes and sets a
lot of limitation when it comes to the
target sequence selection so having
other noble cast nice that can recognize
a different Pam sequence give us more
bandwidth in target selection and
sometimes it can also help to reduce the
off target cleavage so for the SPH at
night it's a smaller or lock then as
pink as night and I just talked about
the size issue so this protein the
smaller I can it's easier force to
express and purified and it also works
better with the viral vector delivery
and people arms through previous studies
have also found that the sba cast nine
has a six nucleotide pam sequence so
it's an NG TGA
so for the noodles for the six
nucleotide sequence it can really
dramatically reduce off target cleavage
but the problem for the SBA cast is that
on previous studies people only observed
cleavage activity in cell 3 conditions
and so in human cell it hasn't been seen
to be up working so we were very curious
to see whether the cmp fusion can be
used to facilitate the editing activity
of the SP a cast 9 so we fused the cmp
fusion to SVA and we also made a little
modification to the SGS RNA scaffold to
make it more stable and among the four
targets that we tested who were really
happy to see some cutting activity of
the SVA cast night and omit at a
moderate level and with the presence of
the cmp fusion the cutting activity
further improved by twofold and we also
exempt the mutation profile of the SP a
calf night and didn't see any
difference between the fusion constructs
and the world type counterpart and we
also delved into the HDR and NH AJ
events after the editing and also see an
improved improvement on the HDR ratio
and for the SP a Kassner however the HDR
versus nhej a ratio remained around 1
between the wild type and the CMP fusion
so it means it didn't have any
preference to choose either of the
repair pathway and I just talked about
sometimes that's the SP SP can I can set
the limitation for the guide selection
and here is an example so sometimes we
have to be very specific on what
sequence we want to edit especially in
these disease mutations and here in this
skeletal malformation associated
mutation we want to edit the mutated
sequence but there is no ngg pam-4 SP
cast 90 recognized so now it becomes
very imperative on for us to have
another set of cast 9 that can recognize
difference hem sequence was to edit so
in actually in nature there have been
about 200 cast 9 proteins and identified
and each of them usually recognize a
different pam sequence and the idea is
the look-alike when we use restriction
enzyme so you have a library of
different enzyme that have recognized
different sequence and so if we can have
that in a castle in a CRISPR system and
it can greatly expand our capacity in
designing the guide sequence and how in
our ability to edit the DNA and enter
milk or Sigma one of our colleague I
worked with some normal cast knives and
he identified the new pam sequence in
for new novel cast proteins and you can
see here on the other slides and I want
to point out here that for the PX cast 9
because at the non-target stream a
strand six nucleotides upstream of the
pam sequence so when the PX do the
cutting it will create a overhanging
sticky end rather than a blunt and
generated by most of the most of other
caste systems and then we are curious to
see whether the cmp fusion can be
applied onto these noble caste night
system as well and so we fused motifs to
the four normal hands nice and we were
also happy to see that it can facilitate
the cutting activity as well so to wrap
up my talk so the chromatin so the
CRISPR chrome strategy is effective in
improving gene editing efficiency and it
has the potential to improve HDR based
the genome editing and it is also a
powerful tool to expand our research
capability on some of the normal council
systems and other applications and we
also didn't see any significant increase
in off target editing by using this
strategy so many poor Sigma has been a
orbit one of the earliest innovator in a
genome editing field and we're
continuing to play a significant role in
this field and we're developing some old
technology for - for the future as well
and that wraps up my talk and with that
we'd like to take some questions